foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
who's the producer of the cryptopia film
thanks Peter five years ago I made a
film about the history of money Banking
and Bitcoin buckle up we said it's going
to be a bumpy ride
and now some of the big brains and big
egos who championed cryptocurrency claim
they are building a crypto Utopia
magical things will happen it's
something called blockchain technology
and it just might change your life and
they really could compete with if not
even take down the Facebooks and the
Googles and the Amazons
my name is tolston Hoffman and I'm going
to put some of these claims to the test
some critics say you kind of hurt the
community what's your response to that
this innovation has enabled a lot of
criminals and scammers but basically
looking at it now you you lie to us
forget all the hype we'll explore the
true potential of this new invention
see who is already using it
making it really easy and simple for
people to own a piece of a solar farm or
a wind farm
and go deep into a secret bunker that
holds billions in Bitcoin
we cannot talk too much about it because
it's pretty secret what is down there
succeeds it will be at least a million
dollars per coin we learn lessons from
the past and meet those building the
future
but they are those who want to kill it
join with me in introducing a bill to
Outlaw cryptocurrency so that we nip
this in the bud control it next year
people are going to start seeing that we
have hundreds of patents and everything
changes or change the world with it
welcome to ground zero in the battle for
the future of the internet web 3.0 they
wanted a science fiction dream what they
actually did was build forthcoming
disaster a lot of people were not
willing to learn and were not willing to
admit they were wrong they're idiots
telling me that I have no clues that's
just [__] if you don't support Free
Speech you don't support Bitcoin you're
an enemy of Bitcoin
the internet the Iron Age The
Renaissance the Industrial Revolution
this affects the entire world
[Music]
for years and years I've been
researching blockchain technology
cryptocurrencies the market booms and
busts and many have asked me to explain
Bitcoin to them but I think this is why
it's so difficult
currency everything you don't understand
about money combined with everything you
don't understand about computers
okay let's start slowly with the basics
of money and its creation
the total value of all the world's money
is about 120 trillion dollars what you
probably didn't know is that each new
dollar is created by governments and
Banks as debt which needs to be paid
back by someone in the future with
interest that's why there isn't enough
money in the world to repay all that
debt and there never will be
oh and almost all of the world's money
is already digital just entries in a
ledger usually managed by a bank
only a small portion exists as physical
currency like cash or coins think of it
this way
your employer deposits a thousand
dollars into your bank account then you
pay 200 in taxes 500 for rent 200 for
bills and shopping and so forth whether
you use credit cards debit cards PayPal
or Bank transfers they're all just
pluses and minuses and different digital
ledgers that's why there's almost no
need for physical money in our daily
lives
during the financial crisis in 2008 a
mysterious figure called Satoshi
Nakamoto published this nine page white
paper it said with bitcoin's open source
software we can create our own money
without banks or governments
[Music]
this new nerd money called
cryptocurrency is created and stored in
computers and before long there was a
growing fan club mostly guys like Roger
avier
today he's a polarizing figure but back
then he gave away thousands of coins to
kick-start the movement and they all
called him Bitcoin Jesus
I think that for many years
he brought more people to bitcoin than
anyone else and we will forever be
grateful to him for doing that
when I was a kid I was reading all these
science fiction books they were talking
about how the world is going to be when
we have this like Anonymous digital
cache that people can use on the
internet that's not controllable by
anybody and then when Bitcoin came along
it was like wow the science fiction
money that I had been reading about as a
kid is finally here so I got so excited
about it I heard about it about 10 in
the morning and I was planning to go to
work that that day but I didn't I stayed
home the entire day reading about it
didn't leave I stayed up all night that
night reading about it stayed up all
night the next night he went deep down
that rabbit hole to the point of
physical exhaustion the hospital side
called up a friend of mine said please
help me I'm so sick can you bring me to
the hospital yeah Roger got bit bad by
the Bitcoin bug
because it's truly one of the most
exciting inventions ever in the entire
history of humankind
but how does it work
when my friends asked me to explain well
I often start with this analogy
imagine a bank vault where you have a
safety deposit box
the key opens one of the boxes where you
can securely store physical valuables
like gold coins
in Bitcoin there are digital keys
think of them as very long passwords
your private key gives you access to a
wallet which unlocks billions of unique
Bitcoin addresses
each one is a virtual safety deposit box
that only you can open with your key
and there are more addresses in this
virtual Vault than atoms in the universe
the doors to these boxes are transparent
you can see inside them
here's one with digital money 0.21
Bitcoins
setting them from one box to another is
what's called a Bitcoin transaction
we'll explain that later but for now
just remember that these digital coins
can only exist inside these transparent
address boxes can't be copied and can't
ever leave the vault
and this vault is owned by no single
entity you don't need permission from a
government a bank or a corporation to
use it
[Applause]
[Music]
for most early adopters of Bitcoin it
was all about global peer-to-peer
electronic cash
room 77 in Berlin was one of the very
first businesses to accept Bitcoins as
payment for physical things beers and
burgers back in 2011 there were no
mobile wallets right so you had to go
there bring your laptop type in this
long address you know risk losing the
money if you didn't type it correctly
so the the first guy who built a
motorbike wall was some guy in Berlin
who built it in order to buy his beer
with his phone instead of his computer
connections
foreign
cards are an old technology and actually
pretty complex and your payment details
are shared with many middlemen
each of these parties are also taking a
cut of the action which is built into
the price of nearly everything you buy
if you purchase something
internationally double the number of
middlemen and triple fees
credit cards handle almost 20 trillion
dollars of transactions per year
early Bitcoin adopters like room 77
avoided paying credit card fees but ux
real beef was with the bankers who
collect them
foreign
[Music]
collapsing economies murder I didn't
sign up for this let me get a drink well
actually I need to buy my German crew
some hot gluevine and explain why they
won't get paid until after Christmas
you see transferring money from
Australia where I live to Germany can
take several days and it will cost
thirty dollars plus exchange fees just
for updating numbers in digital ledges
[Music]
after all it's just moving data I can
send a picture or video to anyone on the
planet almost instantly for free
we live in the age of the internet but
the banks won't send the data after 5 PM
or on a weekend that doesn't make any
sense
so what if those slow and expensive
middlemen with their multiple Ledges
could be replaced by a giant database
synchronized over the Internet that's
the big idea behind Bitcoin and it's run
by a decentralized Global Network of
powerful mining computers and regular
laptops
here's how it works
when I pay my cameraman what's really
happening is that I use my key to open
my wallet and then instruct the network
to send Bitcoins to his address
most Bitcoin apps use QR codes to
identify an address
scan it then swipe to use your key and
approve the transaction
this information is shared throughout
the global Network within seconds
[Music]
every 10 minutes or so one Miner using a
tremendous amount of energy beats all
the others in a contest to solve a very
difficult math problem that minor is
authorized to arrange the most recent
transactions into a structured block and
is rewarded in Bitcoins for this work
all of the data contained inside each
block is represented by a checksum
The Miner now adds the new block to the
previous one that's why it's called the
blockchain Now The Ledger will be
updated globally
the checksums of the previous block
match the beginning of the new one which
are baked together forever
possible to Tinker with the data inside
the block without changing the checksums
and Breaking the Chain
this immutability is the first rule of
Bitcoin it means no one can ever change
what was once recorded in the blockchain
or spent the same coin twice that's also
called censorship resistance and it's
critical to bitcoin being used as real
money
[Music]
award-winning journalist Laura Shin
tells me a story about women bloggers in
Afghanistan being paid in Bitcoin one of
the women had an abusive husband and
saved up her Bitcoins and eventually was
able to divorce him because she was able
to control her money when she earned the
Bitcoins
in my first film The Early adopters said
that this kind of Financial Freedom for
everyone was just around the corner
world's most populous network is
adopting Bitcoin that's the internet the
world's largest economy is adopting
Bitcoin that's the internet we have
transcended borders it's totally failed
as electronic cash David Gerard says it
has unbanked the banked more than it has
banked the unbanked he's an outspoken
critic of this technology
it's not very good as a payment system
there's a small payment use case if you
want to trade in things that the
government doesn't want you to trade in
that's David's polite way of saying
illegal stuff in 2011 most of my partner
colleagues were saying three things yeah
so what are the drugs pornography arm
sales
the Silk Road was a black market on the
dark web where buyers and sellers use
Bitcoins to fly under the radar of the
authorities
it had 1 million users until the FBI
showed up and shot it down they caught
this guy for running it and confiscated
the coins held in escrow by snatching
his computer and then they locked him
away for life seems like a pretty
straightforward case of law enforcement
doing their job but in crypto not
everybody sees it that way
people have an absolute right to put
whatever they want in their own bodies
because their bodies belong to them that
makes Ross Albrecht and the users of the
Silk Road Heroes not criminal
lawbreakers in a bad sense they were
criminal lawbreakers in a good sense the
same way that Harriet Tubman or Rosa
Parks or you know Thomas Jefferson or or
George Washington were
no doubt cryptocurrencies can be a tool
for criminal activity
but so on dollar bills or the banking
system and let's not forget the
blockchain is a public Ledger
it's actually been quite useful for
uncovering crimes a former Federal
prosecutor named Catherine Hahn she was
the one who discovered that there were a
couple federal agents that
were pilfering the Bitcoins that the
government had obtained from the Silk
Road case for their own gain
and what was interesting was she got a
tip that there might be one uh one agent
that was doing this but from looking at
the movements on the blockchain itself
she realized that there were two people
the prosecutor could see those Bitcoins
being moved and when the dirty cops try
to sell them for dollars they got busted
but what makes bitcoins worth stealing
why do they have value at all
let's go back to where Bitcoins are
stored in transparent digital deposit
boxes protected by strong cryptography
they can never be copied or leave the
Vault because any transaction of any
Bitcoin down to a 100 millionth fraction
is recorded in the blockchain for
eternity
this synchronized Global Ledger is
shared among thousands of computers
worldwide that's why it can't be
compromised or altered think about that
we can make an infinite number of
perfect digital copies of a movie a song
any file but for the first time in
history this distributed record keeping
allows us to have a truly unique and
fungible digital object that is also
scarce
if you could count all of these virtual
coins you'd find about 18 million of
them today
the mining reward is the only way new
coins are created
in the first years of Bitcoin miners
competed for 50 Bitcoins every 10
minutes
then their reward for processing
transactions dropped to 25 Bitcoins then
12.5 and then half again and again every
four years
it's good old-fashioned supply and
demand
if investors or users of Bitcoin create
a higher demand than this decreasing
Supply the price will go up
when the cap of 21 million is reached
the protocol stops the network from
creating anymore
it's the opposite of our traditional
money supply which keeps growing and
growing
an unlimited amount of dollars versus a
very limited supply of Bitcoins you do
the math
if you use Euros or dollars you might
not care about a little inflation per
year but if your currency isn't stable
you might be a trillionaire paper and be
dead broke
I grew up in Patagonia in the southern
part of Argentina my parents are ship
ranchers there and I remember growing up
in my childhood I saw my parents lose
everything three times first because of
a huge devaluation then because of
hyperinflation and the last time because
the government confiscated all
of Bank deposits I think that today
there are billions of people at least
four billion people who would be a lot
better off by having access to a form of
money that is non-political and and more
democratic
Finance we think of banking we think of
money in terms of the experience and
perspective of a Western European or
developed Nation person
and that is really just a billion and a
half people who have a very privileged
Financial life what about the other six
billion every single country that is
free has
um essentially a legal status for
cryptocurrencies that is very open and
permissive in every single country that
is unfree has a restrictive or banned uh
cryptocurrency status
all right
this is the Berlin Wall still a powerful
symbol of a government trying to control
its citizens
but this is what happens when people
want to be free
the very first open crypto war is
playing out in Venezuela where the local
currency loses value every hour due to
hyperinflation a lot of people in
Venezuela are trying to mine
cryptocurrencies and the government
abuse this as a threat obviously because
they're trying to keep the boulevard
propped up the government actually
provides electricity to a lot of people
and if they perceive that your
electricity has usage has gone up they
will come and check if you have mining
equipment in your house and they will
confiscate it if they if they find it
and that brings us to the big question
can governments or Banks ban Bitcoin so
the title is Jamie Diamond here's why
you're wrong about Bitcoin
Diamond runs JPMorgan Chase one of the
largest banks in the world that moves
six trillion dollars every single day oh
you said of Bitcoin eventually it will
be closed
and then I said to anyone who knows
anything about the technology this is an
incredibly absurd statement
I even said it was a little bit
hilarious because actually I did find it
kind of funny the idea that he thought
you could close Bitcoin you'd have to
shut down the internet which also
doesn't make sense I could understand if
he wanted Bitcoin shut down or hoped it
was a fraud I mean if I were you and if
I really understood the disruption
crypto assets could bring to financial
services I'd be very scared and I think
whatever Jamie Diamond says or thinks
about Bitcoin is as relevant as whatever
the Postmaster General thought or said
about email
who cares then I wrote sincerely Laura
shin
but some politicians still think they
can stop open source software
I look for colleagues to join with me in
introducing a bill to Outlaw
cryptocurrency purchases by Americans so
that we nip this in the bud in part
because
not a awful lot of our international
power comes from the fact that the
dollar is the standard unit of
international finance and transactions
clearing through the New York fed is
critical for major oil oil and other
transactions and it is that the
announced purpose of the supporters of
cryptocurrency to take that power away
from us
cryptocurrency represents a litmus test
for governments it reveals how much your
government believes in uh in the
fundamental freedoms and and human
rights because if they don't trust their
own citizens to have control over their
own money that says a lot about the
governments there's very little about
cryptocurrency
you see the reason why some governments
in most banks are threatened by this
technology is simple your private key
and your wallet can replace your bank
account
the network is run by software and its
currencies made and maintained by
computing power and electricity it can't
be manipulated by Central Bankers Wall
Street lobbyists or politicians but with
New Freedom comes new responsibility
if you control the keys it's your
pinpoint if you don't control the keys
it's not your Bitcoin your keys your
Bitcoin not your keys not your Bitcoin
your keys your Bitcoin not your keys not
your Bitcoin and got that if you lose
your key you will never be able to
access your coins again and if someone
hacks your computer where you store
those passwords your coins will be
stolen in a second and remember how
wences family had their money stolen by
their own government well maybe that's
why he built the Fort Knox of Bitcoin
security example most of our 7 million
customers are in Emerging Market in
countries where there's problems with
the currency we have explosions in
activity like Venezuela right now or
turkey and we developed this system of
Vault where we have five private keys
for each one of our Bitcoin addresses we
keep those private keys
in an offline server that has never been
online will never be online it's inside
the Vault the vault is inside a banker
usually deep underground our main one is
in Switzerland in the commission
military bunker
I just had to see it for myself even
though it took months for us to get
cleared for a tour
we were met by Christoph Oswald a former
military commander who runs the place
and a representative from sample
Christoph said the guards would rather
shoot us than show us around
I hope he was kidding they need to bring
in the material to the other side of the
personal lock
first up one more check of our IDs a pat
down for weapons or any other Monkey
Business and gear inspection
even the boss was searched
it took nearly an hour to get my team
through security but it was worth it no
other film crew has been allowed access
we are the largest custodian of Bitcoin
in the world because a lot of the
largest holders in the world use us for
security
rumor has it that 10 of all Bitcoins are
stored here and in their four other
Secret locations
unfortunately I can't confirm any of
those numbers
from the mountain we are getting a lot
of benefits right earthquake proof
flooding proof but on the other side
you're facing a lot of additional cost
like maintaining seven independent
backup power supplies
foreign
of tunnels deep into the mountain is
interrupted by nuclear-grade doors
it's a level of security applied to all
of the data Christoph protects here not
just for example
and we cannot talk too much about it
because it's pretty secret what is down
there right are we allowed to film there
no
there were doors that remained shut and
security measures we weren't allowed to
see
and some of those checks may be
biometric including the eye and the
finger Prince can and the fingerprint
scanner also makes sure that you are
alive so that you didn't cut someone's
finger and you're just using it to open
a gate yeah so you must have a pulse
don't don't touch the rest
these aren't set for actual service but
if you've ever wondered what
cryptocurrency thieves dream about it's
sitting somewhere down here unplugged
from the internet but there is
absolutely no way zero way to attack the
data which is on the cold storage side
but here's my question why do I need the
cold offline service to be inside a
mountain how can it be in my basement to
buy all these surveys in your basement
if you still can be stolen right so so
this is like money it is Data yes it's
it's been and buy it but it is money at
the end and a lot of money and this is
why this type of Center he is more a
bank than a data center
okay let's do a quick recap we now have
billions of dollars worth of data
secured in digital Banks deep inside
secret military bunkers if you don't
think Bitcoin is already changing the
world's concept of money you haven't
been paying attention
remember Mervin he used to be a senior
executive at Deutsche Bank his
colleagues once said Bitcoin was for law
Breakers and troublemakers he now runs a
100 million dollar crypto fund out of
Malta
our research shows that
the crypto markets are going to probably
be worth about 8.7 trillion in 2027
which is a 50x from today exactly
[Music]
most Financial analysts say you better
stick to your shares and bonds and
dollars Bitcoin is dangerous nonsense
far too risky as investment
to others Bitcoin is an escape hatch
that will take them away from risk and
insurance against a financial doomsday a
way out of the debt crisis negative
interest rates trade Wars and economic
downturn
they say it's an anti-fragile asset
uncorrelated to financial markets so
who's right here well every time I turn
on the television it gets even more
confusing a bitcoin's worth about a
little bit under 200 billion dollars
today all the gold in the world world is
worth 8 trillion and it could become the
next gold in terms of cryptocurrencies
generally uh I can say almost with
certainty that that they will come to a
bad ending but if Bitcoin is out there
and gold is out there it can be a
participant in bringing down the dollar
I said it's the mother of all Bubbles
and is also the biggest bubble in human
history I think this is a currency a
currency that's really going to work
eventually well I think it is working
um and there will be other currencies
like it that may maybe even better
Bitcoin is uh successful only because of
its potential for circumvention uh lack
of oversight so it seems to me it ought
to be outlawed it doesn't serve any
socially useful function
this film is an investment advice but it
strikes me that most of these TV shows
just want to stir a controversy
they don't understand what's going on
but they know that filling airtime is a
controversial topic will get them higher
ratings
so how about the General Public
in America the younger generation
already starts to trust this new asset
class and when success Bitcoin May reach
a million dollars per coin
I would say the biggest Financial
mistake you can make right now is to own
an amount of Bitcoin that you cannot
afford to lose because it's super risky
and you may lose the second biggest
Financial mistake you can make is not to
own any because
you put one percent of your net worth in
Bitcoin most people can afford to lose
one percent of their net worth and if I
am right it's gonna be more than 100 of
your network so with a non-material
exposure you change your life now what
you would spend with your on a romantic
weekend with your wife
say sorry we're not gonna do that this
weekend I'm gonna just buy Bitcoin
consider it spent it disappeared check
in seven years
I either gave you bad advice and cost
you a weekend or I want a grandkid
called juancito
[Laughter]
but what you fail to mention is the the
currency the microtransactions all of
that is relevant right meaning
all of the cryptocurrencies are way too
volatile for anyone to take them
seriously
hold on let's go back to where we
started Bitcoin was created as
peer-to-peer electronic cash that was
the killer app a payment directly from
you to me from me to the coffee shop
I have bought a bag of coffee for two
Bitcoin in 2012.
which today cost me twelve thousand
dollars in today's money that is a
deflationary effect as long as Bitcoin
keeps doing sudden increases in prices
that's going to stop retail use in its
tracks with Bitcoin you can send one
dollar or one million dollars worth of
value anywhere in the world you can do
it for free
but basically looking at it now you you
lie to us
yeah that's what they all used to tell
me cheap easy fast Global Unstoppable
I'm not done with you pal but I need to
explain what happened here
every block contains about one megabyte
of data much smaller than a photo you
post on Instagram
that means only a limited number of
transactions can fit into each block if
you want your payment to jump the line
you can choose to pay a premium fee or
sit and wait
at one point the blocks became so full
that the transaction time went to
several hundred hours that's days
and it was more expensive than
International wire services
it got so bad that a Bitcoin conference
wouldn't take payment in Bitcoins and
he's the guy who promised me moving
money fast and for free what went wrong
and that's as a direct intentional
result of Bitcoin course policies of
intentionally making it slow expensive
and unreliable and Roger blames this guy
for Bitcoin not becoming a mainstream
Global Currency
there are no shortage of conspiracy
theories
block stream was founded in 2014 the
original co-founders are a lot of core
developers those are the software coders
who continued building Bitcoin after
Satoshi vanished Roger thinks those guys
sabotaged the scaling of the network so
blockstream could promote its own
software Solutions Simpson says come on
the blockchain is already 200 gigabytes
large and growing every transaction made
has to go out to the whole network and
every block that contains that
transaction that is mined has also got a
whole network and it has to be stored
for eternity
the argument more independent miners
will continue running Bitcoin and ensure
decentralization if the blockchain is
kept small in his view this
decentralization is what makes Bitcoin
valuable a store of value
so holding Bitcoin is also a use case
and that store value hypothesis I cannot
get my head around it's the most
like nutty thing I've ever heard you
know one philosophy could be described
as Bitcoin as digital goals and the
other philosophy could be described as
Bitcoin as digital cash
the other team said you guys have it the
wrong way around first Bitcoin needs to
be usable as a currency a medium of
exchange then maybe it will become
stable and a store of value
the solution is easy and just increase
the size of the blocks from 1 to 2 4 8
megabytes so that more transactions fit
into them
this will lower the fees and people will
start using Bitcoin as cash again the
original title of the Bitcoin white
paper is Bitcoin and electronic
peer-to-peer electronic cash system but
you know satoshi's white paper isn't the
Bible it's not a religion it's tough
changes we evolve we might find out new
things so why this
fixation on that white paper
um you know created 10 years ago there
isn't any fixation it's not the version
of Bitcoin that I got involved with and
it's not the version of Bitcoin that I
want to support
so Roger joined forces with a
controversial online gambling
billionaire bitmaine a Chinese crypto
mining company and this guy I'll do
whatever the [__] I want with my money
okay anyway they forced the software
Fork which is a split into two separate
blockchains every holder of Bitcoin now
also owned the same amount of Bitcoin
cash Roger had nothing to do with the
creation of Bitcoin cash project didn't
know about it until a few weeks before
it actually happened but still Bitcoin
Jesus had become Bitcoin Judas every
Revolution is followed by the counter
Revolution which is usually a purge of
the original revolutionaries people
are very passionate about Bitcoin and
that's why they they show a lot of
emotion when you're part of a tribe you
get very religious about your tribe
making the other tribe almost your enemy
it's very hard to
to debate Roger because a lot of what
he's saying is just his opinions and his
emotions you cannot debate someone's
emotions and then they basically
diverted the entire Bitcoin project
into something that wasn't usable as
peer-to-peer Cash when he gave his talk
I kind of knew that that whole debate
panel I kind of expected it was kind of
got the rails but I didn't expect
killing babies so that means more babies
are dying in countries around the world
because they have less economic freedom
more people are starving to death
people are literally dying because of
this I'm not exaggerating this is a life
and death matter
and remember that list of promises the
early Bitcoin has championed cheap easy
fast Unstoppable I forgot one if you
don't support Free Speech you don't
support Bitcoin you're an enemy of
Bitcoin censorship shall not be abided
in fact I myself have tried posting just
a direct quote from Satoshi Nakamoto the
creator of Bitcoin I think Rogers
complains a lot about censorship on on
Reddit so red is just one of many like
platforms word for word quote from
Satoshi without any additional
commentary for myself at all and I've
had that post deleted even though I may
not agree with a lot of things that
Roger where is doing now I do sympathize
with him and his frustration with being
censored they're literally censoring the
words of the creator of Bitcoin
ultimately this is a forum that these
guys set up to talk about Bitcoin and
they can do whatever they want with it
right
when I first started covering the space
everyone was United in their struggle
against establishment now the industry
has grown so much that they are
competing parties propaganda machines
conspiracy theories looks a lot like
politics
the biggest fight within the Bitcoin
ecosystem is over at the moment is who
has the right to the name Bitcoin but at
the end of the day I think the version
of Bitcoin described in the Bitcoin
white paper has the strongest claim to
the name Bitcoin than anything else and
that's Bitcoin cash Roger owns
bitcoin.com and he has every intention
of bringing Bitcoin cash to the masses
even if it means that some people coming
to his website think that they're buying
Bitcoin but they're getting Bitcoin cash
I think it's fraudulent to say that and
causing people to to buy Bitcoin cash
when they actually want to buy Bitcoin
yeah
Sting is foreign
so Bitcoin core fans say Roger's
hijacking the brand name and Bitcoin
cash supporters claim that block stream
is hijacking bitcoin's development I
mean yeah it is a conflict of interest
because they're developing this open
source protocol in a way where their
company can can benefit from it
everything we're doing is open source so
it's not like there's some secrecy or
anything you can see all the code that's
committed and it does go through this
vetting process I mean they have had
influence I mean I wouldn't say
uh it's not true but I don't think
um they have enough influence to
actually corrupt uh Bitcoin uh we no
longer have anyone maintaining the
project just because we don't want that
potential conflict of interest but in a
way now they've won the battle anyways
so who won bitcoin's first war well both
parties got their way
after the split the market valued
Bitcoins much higher and Bitcoin cash
transaction fees were much lower
the benefit of the scaling debate or
Civil War was Bitcoin was Battle tested
like a lot of companies and a lot of
powerful people tried very hard to try
to change Bitcoin and they failed this
thing that Satoshi Nakamoto launched is
much more resilient than anyone even
hoped
I know I know you want to find out what
any of this has to do with this new
cryptopia a revolutionary internet we'll
get there I promise but first we need to
go from bitcoin's original blockchain to
hundreds of blockchains
back in 2011 when Charlie Lee was a
Google engine here he wanted a faster
and lighter version of satoshi's
cryptocurrency
and was one of the first to experiment
with the open source software
the actual coding in terms of like the
code differences between Bitcoin and
Litecoin was actually pretty trivial and
what does that mean in time like
uh I would say like four four or five
hours Litecoin was positioned as silver
to bitcoin's gold and its Network value
grew to billions of dollars some critics
say well you sold at the highest point
and you kind of hurt the community once
you responds to that when I sewed no one
knew it was the highest point I didn't
know it was going to be the highest
point so everyone thought it was going
to keep going up in hindsight um it was
good timing um selling it at the high
but I'm still focused full-time on
Litecoin adoption and working on
Litecoin Micron development so it's not
like I saw it and just quit
um nobody gets to kind of dictate how
Bitcoin improves or or grows whereas
with Litecoin I have a a strong
influence on the growth of Litecoin
which is good and bad it's kind of like
um difference between the benevolent
dictator versus a democracy the
Netherland dictator is more efficient
but you have to assume that the benavon
dictator stays Penelope let's put a pin
in that Litecoin was one of the first
alternative cryptocurrencies or altcoins
some of the early adopters like Charlie
made fortunes soon there were hundreds
of coins made by cryptographers copycats
and con man
there's a coin for bloggers a currency
for online Gamers one with anonymity and
even one for banks but can this
invention unleash something even more
powerful than digital currencies
back in 2014 I met the kid who knew how
to do it hi I'm vitalik murderen a
co-founder of Bitcoin magazine founder
of ethereum and just general Bitcoin and
cryptocurrency Advocate just 19 years
old vitalik was on a mission to make
money programmable
vitalik is a very very smart guy the
thing about metallic is he was pushed
away from Bitcoin because he had gone to
bitcoin core developers and tried to
build ethereum on top of Bitcoin and and
they basically said nope not interested
so he built a separate blockchain called
ethereum with its own currency called
ether comparison might be Bitcoin is
like a spreadsheet and ethereum is like
a spreadsheet with macros
using our analogy ethereum allows you to
store cryptocurrency and computer code
in the same secure box
here's how a smart contract might work
let's say I bet Charlie that a Litecoin
will be worth 200 on January 1st of next
year
we each put an ether into a box along
with a smart contract a simple program
that automatically checks the price of
litecoins on that future date if I'm
right the money goes to me if I'm wrong
it's sent to Charlie
foreign
contract is neither smart nor contract
it's a dumb program and it once you
understand that all it is is on program
that clarifies a lot of stuff and the
word contract there is in the meaning of
Finance
most Financial arrangements are pretty
simple and clear-cut a bed with Charlie
your home loan an insurance policy just
two parties and some form of exchange of
value based on a set of rules called a
contract the same is true for Global
Financial markets think bonds Futures
derivatives credit default swaps they're
all just contracts and the world economy
runs on them using middlemen who all
charge High fees proponents say that if
we used smart contracts we could tell
the bankers lawyers escrow agents and
Wall Street Finance guys to take a hike
a soda machine is a smart contract
machine right you stick in a dollar you
get a soda it's very very simple the
soda machine does take statistics and it
has to make sure that you can't scam it
by stealing the soda but ethereum and
the people that are trying to
decentralize this will tell you that
that transaction that smart contract
between you and the soda machine is so
critical that it needs to be globally
processed and saved at a hundred
thousand decentralized computers because
it is so sensitive and in reality 99 of
all of these contracts they don't need
this kind of censorship resistance you
know in two years time and people will
see this film on for this time I think
will be an interesting historic moment
also what we're dealing is we're saying
we have this ethereum network inside the
ethereum network there's this asset
called ether and we're actually going to
be selling ether we're going to be
selling ether at a rate of 1000 to 2000
ether for one Bitcoin and that's how
we're going to raise all the money it
worked vitalik figured out a way to fund
the ethereum project and it made his
investors very rich
new model for fundraising soon had a
name an initial coin offering or Ico
IPOs and icos sound similar but they
have they're nothing similar the only
thing similar about them is they both
help you raise money
IPOs you don't do until you have a
company until you have Revenue until you
have users until you actually prove to
the public investors that this is a
valuable company that's worth investing
and it's worth buying their stock
icos it's pre-product you have maybe a
couple people on the team it's just a
white paper and so people are just
buying into trust into faith that this
is something that will exist and this is
the guy who opened the floodgates he
created a standard called esc20 enabling
you or me or anyone to create an Ico
so on the one hand you have the smart
contracts these little programs that can
talk to each other but you have to
Define how do they talk to each other
and because everybody now agrees to that
same standard
smart contracts can interact within the
entire ethereum network and the erc20
standard allowed the creation of tokens
the goal here is like ultimately I like
to see eight-year-olds building their
own Financial systems
yeah but what if some of these
eight-year-olds are also scammers so
let's say I'm trying to do a Ico and I
create a smart contract where I create a
million coins and one of the
transactions is that if you send me a
hundred dollars I will send you that
many worth of coins
it was a Mad Gold Rush
realized wow if if I can just pull up
pull together a project in a white paper
I can raise money like a lot of money
some people Hawking new coins didn't
actually exist this handsome chap is the
graphic designer of a Bulgarian Ico
actually they just posted a photo of
Ryan Gosling another project raised
millions in ether and then vanished
leaving investors with this website look
closer that's nice
most of the scam coins were built on
vitalik Smart contract platform ethereum
using fabian's token standard
this innovation has enabled a lot of
criminals and scammers
um
so I would say the amount of scams in
the in in that system are rather low it
sometimes looks bigger than it is I
would I would assume that the actual
scams purposeful proper for scams in
that system maybe were like two or three
percent I would say actually most icos
were
not scams I would say about two to five
percent of the thousands of icos that
are happening are actually legit and the
rest is
pretty scammy or just not gonna work
can you define
for me what a [__] coin is
um I think it's just a derogatory term
people use
on coins that they don't like for
Bitcoin maximalists people who only care
about Bitcoin everything else is a [__]
coin
in my point of view I think a coin that
is kind of a scam is a [__] coin so
people create coins just to get rich
from it uh print a lot of tokens out of
thin air trying to pump the price up and
make a lot of money from it and that's
not really providing a lot of value uh
to the to the world no value for the
world but they did add value for their
creators if you can print billions of
tokens out of thin air like a central
bank well that's why this guy was one of
the wealthiest men on Earth for a brief
moment
here's how that happened
we'll only ever be 21 million Bitcoins
and its inventor had to earn them by
mining with his computers just like
everyone else there are more litecoins
and even more ether in circulation
vitalik kept some portion to fund the
development team and then there's Ripple
they created a hundred billion xrp but
kept 80 for themselves and their clients
and the other 20 they gave as a bonus to
the founders that's how you get to be
one of the richest men on Earth
okay maybe I was a bit too harsh on icos
democratizing Startup Finance can be a
good thing there were many legit
companies raising Capital too over the
years I've met many Founders who have
real offices with real people trying to
solve real problems
but to bitcoin maximalists Bitcoin is
the be all and all of cryptocurrency
other blockchains icos smart contracts
that's all a waste of time
go back there is no such thing as
blockchains
originalize the health care industry and
the automotive
oh of course it is what you're saying is
the maximalist point of view you are
speaking about uh from a perspective of
of a cult or a set
my problem is that you are hijacking a
movement of a technology that is far
greater and has far more potential than
just these individuals there's all of
these different things that you could
use blockchain for right and so people
have they're almost like different
ecosystems and then what you see is
almost like an evolutionary process
right where the blockchains fork and
they have the same ancestries but they
adapt to different environments and we
see this like ever increasing level of
diversity in number of blockchains so I
think the idea that there's like one
blockchain going to be one blockchain
and it's going to be fit for everything
it is almost like disregarding the
nature of evolution
meanwhile the big corporations have been
studying cryptocurrency and they think
that bitcoin's underlying database is
where the magic is the model in the
boardrooms
blockchain not Bitcoin
[Music]
back in Germany my friend Oliver keeps
tabs on the men in suits
used to be one of them
[Music]
is
BMW is looking at using the blockchain
for the future Fleet of electric cars to
interact with public transport
Lufthansa wants to see if the blockchain
can better track parts and maintenance
and Deutsche Telecom is using smart
contracts to negotiate tariffs for
roaming costs with other telecoms
if we can store trade certificates and
shipping documents on the blockchain you
can check to see where those organic
avocados really came from who grew them
who packed them and who shipped them
besides the Internet of Things needs a
ledger of all those things
well that's the idea behind private
centralized blockchains maintained and
controlled by corporations a famous
example the Walmart supply chain trial
which they're working with IBM
that's completely centralized they use a
blockchain derived product type of
Ledger but all the nodes reside on the
IBM cloud and they're all administered
by Walmart and their suppliers used
because Walmart told them to it's a
centralized database system but they
marked it blockchain so that means one
they wouldn't have got a New York Times
headline if they've just said database
you might wonder what's the point of a
blockchain if it's controlled by a
company well I compare it to the open
internet versus company-owned intranets
they both exist
meanwhile Facebook announced the
cryptocurrency for their 2 billion users
such a system might be more efficient
than a public blockchain but there's a
downside some governments banned it
within weeks
right now the ways pieces of paper
that's being shifted around that doesn't
make any sense that infrastructure needs
to be replaced why Occupy Wall Street
when we can build a new one on the
blockchain instead
in the future of decentralized Finance
stock certificate corporate bonds
insurance policies property Deeds
mortgages all can be turned into crypto
tokens and made tradable 24 7.
foreign
what's much more exciting than tokenized
Securities of traditional businesses
where it's just Equity that you pass
around is totally novel digital
Securities that you couldn't do before
right novel use cases where you could
kick back Clash flow on a continual
basis I think some examples of this that
we're seeing now are maker Dow Finance
which is has binance coin that's
actually much bigger of an opportunity
because it represents something totally
new
my name is Dr Gemma green and I'm a
co-founder and the chairman of power
Ledger and we use the blockchain to
enable electricity trading energy asset
financing and carbon markets this
award-winning Australian company wants
to take us to a carbon-free economy
faster Gemma has identified a problem
our apartment buildings often the
buildings are tenanted and it means that
if there is solar panels the owner of
the apartment isn't really incentivized
to put in solar panels or batteries
because the tenant benefits but using
our platform the tenant will pay the
electricity bill to the body corporate
using power Ledger the tenant pays the
owner not the power company for the
electricity if the tenant isn't at home
the unused energy will be sold to a
neighbor lowering their power bill and
making a profit for the owner so it
actually creates the mechanism to
justify investing in the capital in the
first place this system could speed up
investment in sustainable energy
projects by making it easy to own a
piece of solar or wind farm
why do I need a blockchain for this
can't I invest in a solar farm without
this new fancy tank the blockchain acts
as a kind of asset register and income
register and in tokenizing the asset it
becomes tradable on an exchange you
might own two or three solar panels of a
thousand you know you know in a solar
farm and you would receive the income
associated with that amount of ownership
now Bankers don't very much like being
cut out of the cash flow Loop so they
took another look at Mr nakamoto's
curious little white paper and they've
recently been spending a billion dollars
a year in blockchain research
isn't it ironic satoshi's anti-bank
invention has now been used by the Banks
to move money faster and by big business
to track Supply chains
[Music]
cryptocurrencies and digital tokens
public blockchains private blockchains
where is the killer app well adoption of
new technology often follows old trends
my name is Mark ventresca I'm here at
Oxford University of Oxford on the
faculty I'm an economic sociologist by
training interested in how large-scale
infrastructure changes so great to see
you after nine years I think
mock teaches a class on Innovation and
system building
he tells me what must align for a new
technology to become fruitful all
Technologies start out as interesting
ideas some of them begin to develop into
Innovations and we know that that Arc
from invention to Innovation takes a lot
of time it takes a lot of work some of
those Innovations eventually become
commercially viable
case in point the automobile in the
early days cars looked like a pretty
lousy idea and poorly executed
early on there were electric cars there
were battery operated cars the
combustion engine was a relative
latecomer it took Henry Ford's mass
production to create the standards what
a car looked like what parts it needed
how it operated
that's when complementary assets and
infrastructure emerged so you have paved
roads and petrol stations then you have
secondary things like motels and
restaurants and places to eat while
you're on the highway and buy food then
you have interesting questions like what
side of the road should we drive on
an entire ecosystem had been built but
it wasn't a smooth transition by any
means
[Music]
the imagery here is there are maybe a
couple of hundred three or four hundred
companies that try to get into this
space but they're not car companies
they're bicycle manufacturers or steam
engine manufacturers at some point in
this in this account all that period of
ferment settles are under dominant
design and then you have what again what
Innovation economists would call a
ShakeOut they would say you go from
three or four hundred producers all of
them vying to shape this emerging space
this emerging thing called the
automobile you may then drop to 20 or 30
manufacturers and then you may drop to
five or six
it took 50 years for cars to go from
Curious invention to finely tuned Mass
Market product 50 years to change the
World As We Knew It
your destination is on the left
but our story isn't about cars or roads
I want to learn about dominant designs
of digital technology
that's why I came to the Computer
History Museum in the heart of Silicon
Valley so you're looking at the console
for sage which was probably the first
computer network there were 23 centers
around North America to warn against
Soviet bombers and they were waiting for
World War III the U.S military and some
American universities asked this guy to
create a new kind of network to connect
their separate Networks
this young girl got up and she had a
bunch of questions but her first one was
how did I manage to convince all the
governments of the world to let us build
the internet and they said well except
for the handful of us that were actually
working on the internet nobody else
really thought it was a very good idea
and so you didn't think it was going to
lead anywhere and you know we pretty
much had a Free Running Room yes that's
the man who co-invented TCP about 50
years ago that's the original academic
paper you can think of TCP as the
backbone of the internet but back then
there were many competing Technologies
there was a very big battle over the
protocols tcpip didn't just win by
default
it won through attrition by basically
being better simpler easier to deploy
than all of the other scannables and
more scalable and it had a lot of
competition from phone companies that
tried to make the internet a closed
metered controlled system they tried to
do what people are trying to do today
with blockchains which is take the open
decentralized device Network and turn it
into this sterile closed corporate
system where they can charge by the
minute and be in control
victory has a dirty little secret the
men in charge of promoting it were
employees of the military with the
muscle and the cash to beat the
competition and then there's email email
I heard that's really neat
email was perhaps the internet's first
killer app then in the early 90s Tim
berners-lee introduced the World Wide
Web as a 20-page proposal
soon there were browsers that made it
more accessible and user-friendly for
the General Public
foreign
I think that the internet is going to be
one of the major forces
for reducing the role of government
the one thing that's missing but that
will soon be developed is a reliable
e-cash still few understood the
potential of this new tech from people
that thought it would just be the
world's greatest library to some of the
early Cipher punks who are the direct
fathers of crypto and certainly a
blockchain type ideas who thought much
as today that it would create kind of a
Commons that was outside of the direct
control of normal laws and governments
that's ironic because the US government
funded it in the first place the
spiritual forefathers of crypto who
built the early internet thought it was
a new technology for Global freedom of
expression and a blank canvas upon which
they could build their dreams boy that
sounds familiar
and the media they didn't quite know
what to make of this new thing either
but sure enough they found juicy stories
about the dark side of it
which was the internet is full of
criminals and pedophiles and
pornographers and it's too dangerous to
use your credit card on it it's full of
scams we're seeing the exact same story
now we envisioned technology as if it
were autonomous as if it were simply
outside of human and social experience
what we see are technologies that become
shaped by commercial interests by
political and Regulatory infrastructure
by actors who are acting for many
reasons right yeah remember Bob
the big telecoms wanted his thoughts on
a little idea that were kicking around
they had a meeting where they were
trying to figure out how they could buy
the internet they couldn't kill it well
why not own it I got asked that myself
by an executive at a large information
company it was probably in 1990 if they
could buy the internet
I mean I remember asking them well why
don't you buy the world economy they can
own everything why don't you buy the
weather and you can control that too
as the internet's momentum and hype grew
investors threw money at entrepreneurs
and Shady characters
[Music]
the joke in the.com era was that you put
a.com behind your company even if it had
nothing to do with the internet and the
Venture capitalists just throw money at
you it took a few decades and hype
Cycles but the wild internet was
eventually domesticated co-opted by
trillion dollar companies and then
fundamentally transformed how we shop
work and communicate
Speaker's Corner in London's Hyde Park
for 150 years this has been a safe place
to stand on a soapbox to sell you ideas
preach the gospel bad mouth the king or
promote communism
today with the World Wide Web we can
stand on giant digital soap boxes using
Facebook Twitter Youtube we can share
our ideas or start a fight with anyone
on the planet
of the overwhelming majority well almost
anyone
of 65 countries studied China has the
least free internet worse than Iran Cuba
or Syria
a police force of more than 2 million
cyber cops and the world's most
sophisticated artificial intelligence
system keep China's web content clean
and users in check
so sorry to break it to you but there's
no longer a world wide web welcome to
the Splinter net no it's not just in
China in Russia Wikipedia is illegal
Facebook is outlawed in Bangladesh
there's no WhatsApp in Dubai Twitter was
banned in Turkey after news about
government corruption spread and Saudi
Arabia shut down the Region's largest
news service Al Jazeera and the BBC
meanwhile in India the entire web was
turned off 100 times last year
to be fair some of the censorship is to
prevent terrorist recruitment or to stop
violent mobs from hurting people but
think government's control over the
internet has gone just a little too far
hello I'm from the Australian government
do you have something to hide we've
taken the UK's fascist spying law and
made it even more fascist to test this
[__] [__] we chose Australia the
weakest of the five eyes Alliance thanks
to our lack of a Bill of Rights so
international data requests will now be
funneled through US compromising not
just Aussies but all of you [__] too
you're welcome
foreign
money into code code is just letters and
numbers which is speech right so money
now is speech which is a pretty powerful
idea if you think about it but if
Bitcoin is this uncontrollable
unsensible technology can the blockchain
also enable global free speech
in some places it already does
one Chinese student tried to report a
sexual assault and was silenced by her
college but she knew that she could
attach a message into the metadata of an
ethereum transaction so she spent 15
cents and now her letter outlining her
story and the threat she received is on
the public ethereum blockchain where it
will remain unchangeable forever
thank you
the early crypto Pioneers wanted to
democratize money Finance 2.0 if you
will but now the Believers in the
blockchains have their eyes on a bigger
prize they want to decentralize
everything web 3.0
Facebook without the propaganda Twitter
without the terms of service read it
without the censorship online identity
without the hex internet browsing
without tracking software
websites without the advertising
we pay with either attention or privacy
so we either have advertising thrown at
us our attention is monetized or we pay
with micro violations of our privacy and
that is why the internet today is the
ultimate surveillance economy one
privacy tool is the brave browser it
doesn't store data and pays users and
content Publishers in their basic
attention tokens
what most people in the crypto space are
probably most excited about is this
notion that we can create these kind of
user-owned decentralized networks you
can for instance offer file storage in
the way that an Amazon does or that you
could offer search you know the way
Google does but do it in a peer-to-peer
fashion without this behemoth at the
center extracting rents and do it in a
way where all the people that are users
of it can benefit lockstack is the next
evolution in Computing we've seen three
main eras of computing before we had
mainframes that were these large
computers that everyone depended on then
we got desktops where users were in
control and they owned their own
computers and their data and information
and then we saw cloud computing where we
are dependent on these large companies
running services for us and we are about
to embark on this major shift in
Computing called decentralized Computing
where you users are getting back in
control
they really could someday compete with
if not even take down some of the big
Tech giants like the Facebooks and the
Googles and the Amazons that we know
that's a tall tall order it is it is but
I mean who would have thought at the
beginning of the internet that Wikipedia
would beat out in Cardiff these web 3
promises sound good but my professional
network is on LinkedIn my personal
photos are on Instagram if I deleted my
accounts I'd lose everything these
Services aren't just walled Gardens they
are digital prisons data is locked up in
several companies
and we don't own it the companies own it
but they use the data to mine it to
advertise to us to sell us things to
manipulate us to change our behavior and
ocean protocol is the answer to freeing
up the data and giving the power back to
individuals
so how do we plan to do that
it's essentially an operating system on
top of ethereum that allows for people
to share data
storage algorithms
and computation in a way that preserves
privacy it's too early to tell whether
projects like these can succeed but I do
like the idea of digital property rights
would it be nice if companies paid us in
cryptocurrency when they use our data
and if we control who has access to it
instead of our digital overlords
and then there's the question of our
most precious information
our very identity if you take the
history of mankind a lot of blood has
been shared getting to democracy right
the idea that Every Man Has a vote in
the world and you know I take it kind of
personally because I was born in South
Africa during apartheid
um you know the child of Indian
immigrants and we were not allowed to
vote Vinnie tells me that in the United
States alone there are 14 000 different
paper forms of birth certificates issued
by local authorities
there are mistakes on them and even
identity theft starting from birth
all your information is already out
there there's you know five hacks a day
happening so how do you prove that you
are who you say you are
[Music]
our crypto celebrity Andreas has 10
imposters on Instagram Ryan Gosling's
Alter Ego is committing financial fraud
in Bulgaria and who knows what's
happening with your compromised
information
blockchain Based Services like
civicsidentity.com or Microsoft's ion
say they can give us control of our
identity and protect it currently we are
having our reputation our history with
different systems of different companies
like Facebook and Twitter with the
blockchain the core important
information sits on that trusted system
which we control and we can take from
wherever we want to go to something else
meanwhile vitalik has inspired thousands
of software developers to build his
vision of decentralized Finance but
early in ethereum's history something
went wrong with one of the first smart
contracts called the Dao the Dow went
like this they wanted a completely be
decentralized autonomous organization
they wanted a science fiction dream of
an independent computer program that was
immune to human influence
so what they actually did was build a
forthcoming disaster the problem some
sloppy cold left their safety deposit
box wide open and somebody just helped
themselves
allowed them to pilfer 50 million
dollars from the smart contract
and
that's why when when I say it's not even
clear whether or not it was a hack you
know the smart contract allowed them to
do that and what happened was the
majority of the community did decide to
roll back the blockchain and to pretend
like the Dow never happened
yep you heard that correctly the top
decision makers fought ethereum into two
separate networks one where the money
was gone and a new one where the money
was restored to its original owners
breaking the first rule of
cryptocurrency never alter the
blockchain
immutability lasts only as long as the
big boys haven't lost money just like
Bitcoin ethereum also experienced
scaling problems
when a decentralized app called
cryptokitties I'm not kidding went viral
and the kitties spread like rabbits in
its blockchain the system ground to a
halt
the network is now being upgraded but
there are many competitors who claim
that their blockchains are faster fairer
and more scalable the next checkout will
sure be interesting to watch
it's never easy to admit that some that
you've been fooled
um
maybe I've been fooled
uh
Maybe
the crypto Community doesn't agree on
much of anything except when it comes to
this guy
hello my name is Dr Craig Wright I'm the
chief scientist of n chain limited on
the balance of the evidence Craig Wright
almost certainly is not Satoshi Nakamoto
the proof that he gave were not real
proofs in the end he either chickened
out or didn't actually have the proof
Craig Wright obviously it seems to be a
scammer
I'm happy to say that Craig Wright is a
fraud I know he's controversial no one
really changes the world without being
bold without disrupting people's ideas
and without drawing a little controversy
around the way
but the majority of the industry says
Craig is crazy or a con man
Craig kindly joined us on stage and that
giving him screen time is irresponsible
and I'll say this quite frankly because
I've got more money than your country
but I was in the area and just couldn't
resist
[Music]
a few quick facts Craig is the personal
claimed to be Satoshi Nakamoto on the
BBC
but his cryptographic proof didn't check
out and since then many just see him as
an imposter I'm the guy with a law
degree that used to work for federal
police and military intelligence
you would actually be the perfect super
villain for us because everybody kind of
doesn't believe you hates you what do
you say to your critics uh do I start
with
many people
are hated early on because they're not
understood if it doesn't have a use it
shouldn't have a value right now
practically everything is a Ponzi I
don't particularly like ethereum it's a
dead end they can say whatever they want
about erc20 except practically
everything they're doing that they want
to solve I solved years ago
decentralization was never the point of
Bitcoin
ever I was called a fool then and I'll
be called a fool again and every single
time I'll be right
I picked up mastering Bitcoin the other
day and I opened page one
and I went this is wrong
Silk Road was the worst thing to ever
happen to bitcoin you seem to think that
nobody else has anything interesting to
say you've already solved the problems
many years ago that's kind of the the
vibe that I'm getting here fairly much
yes
okay
turns out Craig's Playbook is patents
some say he's a patent troll
well I've got a bucket list bit which is
to beat Edison which um as silly as it
sounds came from a Simpsons episode to
beat Mr Edison I need to get a 1085 and
right at the moment I'm on white paper
1074. for each white paper he claims to
file about 1.1 patents the first 163
will be very shortly public next year
people are going to start seeing that we
have hundreds of patents and
Everything Changes we file PCT and keep
them secret as long as we can
so that's a huge philosophical
disagreement between myself and and
Craig's I think government patents are
government granted Monopoly the big
brains and big eagles who broke away
from Bitcoin couldn't hash out their
differences so there was another split
Craig's new coin also claims to be the
real Bitcoin and he wants to enable
blocks a million times larger updating
and storing this giant blockchain will
be impossible for normal computers I
just can't figure this guy out is he a
genius a Madman a fraud maybe all three
and a lot of things he say are very
um or just wrong technically
however I did calculate that n chain
spent tens of millions of dollars to
develop and file these patents and some
have been granted what's the point of
having a war chest full of Ip if they
aren't going to enforce it so basically
what I'm looking at is stuff that
nobody's ever really seen in the
community that's correct yes as soon as
the price of Bitcoin and the
cryptocurrencies went higher what did
what did most people do all they did was
start adopting all the worst behaviors
of Bankers scamming the market
centralizing wealth in a few hands I
think that's called human nature so
everyone wants to change the world
simply because they're not in the
position of of power as soon as they get
into that position they do exactly the
same thing
so guys like you will build a better
future and we can trust you guys better
than the bankers you don't have to trust
us that's the beauty we're building a
trustless decentralized system that
gives power to people
it sounds like there's no trust but
actually it means we don't need to trust
you I think the better word should be
trust free about one third or maybe half
of all the cost of all the transactions
are paid to establish trust between
trading parties like we're paying for
lawyers we're paying Auditors who are
paying even police even Regulators
government to to build trust to ensure
everything will be enforced so trust is
quite expensive blockchain is the first
time that we saw some technology that
can eliminate the cost or reduce the
cost of trust dramatically magical
things will happen trust may be
expensive but it's also in short supply
all around the globe people have been
losing faith in the media institutions
and governments so what if this new
technology could fix one of society's
biggest issues but the question remains
what if you are cheated what if your
password is stolen and the money the
contracts your identity is gone
if court is law
who administs Justice
to worry that the promise of
decentralizing power is kind of in
jeopardy with you and Charlie and
vitalik and Craig as such Central
figureheads
yeah I really wish there weren't public
figures or leaders I want everyone to
lead themselves but sadly uh that's not
the world we live in if you're going to
look to a leader you know Choose Your
Leader wisely
which is how different are they from our
current political financial and Business
Leaders are their systems really
resistant to corruption immune to
manipulation and worthy of our trust
maybe that's why the best bet is on the
only Project without a figurehead
Bitcoin doesn't care about human Drama
Bad press or what anyone thinks yeah
sure it hasn't succeeded as a Global
Currency yet but in the past decade it
has been the world's best performing
financial asset
so we're back to where we started the
genius who vanished
with Satoshi being gone from Bitcoin
Bitcoin is really a very decentralized
Network and currency he was intelligent
enough to know that
a system without a father was going to
be much more robust than a system with a
father
no father maybe but without leaving a
will the kids are now fighting over the
meaning of his invention and The
Inheritance projecting their fears and
their fantasies onto his legacy
for some it's money for the internet
that can replace middlemen and Bank the
unbanked and maybe a tool for illicit
trade or is it digital gold a totally
new asset class a bet against the
bankers and insurance against inflation
protection from corrupt politicians
and a weapon against the state maybe the
end of money as we know it
for some entrepreneurs it represents a
shortcut to fund their dreams a platform
for fairer Finance which is why
incumbents fight it
some say public blockchains are just
slow and useless databases while big
business is busy building private
blockchains to boost efficiency or maybe
this decentralized technology is a new
protocol layer for the internet upon
which we can build a better web
to Dethrone the tech Giants reclaim Free
Speech protect online identities and
facilitate free trade in a borderless
digital economy oh and a tool to rebuild
trust in our societies and yes maybe
even save the planet
that's a never-ending list of cryptopian
ideas
there's a bit too much to ask of a nine
page document
yeah sure the internet and the web
started out as white papers too but it
took decades before its infrastructure
was built became user friendly and ready
to scale globally we kind of domesticate
the wild potential of Technologies into
what's familiar and we've dramatically
underestimate or under imagine what that
technology may eventually do
it'll be the users maybe billions of
them who will adopt this technology
without even knowing what a blockchain
is or how it works
here's the thing the average users don't
care about the wires that move their
money quicker don't know about the
software that moves this movie or that
picture
what will move them are services that
will make the days a little brighter
their chores a little lighter
and their lives a little
richer
[Music]
cause I don't wanna cause a ripple
don't wanna cause
[Music]
with my life
oh
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
my darling let's go
[Music]
that corn is gone